here's how to play the Mario Kart
drinking game for this game you'll need
three things
a pack of cheap beer two to four players
and any generation of Mario Kart from
the new Wii U version all the way back
to Super Nintendo even though we all
know n64 is the best the rules of the
game are simple crack open a beer to
start the race the first player to cross
the finish line wins
but you must finish your beer before you
finish the race the only other rule is
that your Kart must be a complete stop
before you drink your beer because not
even Mario tolerates drinking and
driving but you know drinking right
after driving that's cool but don't take
our word for how awesome it is here are
some people trying out the game for the
first time
wait till you drink while you're playing
so easy just chug it in the beginning no
at least most of it what's gonna
backfire I really want to see you do
that we're about to do it it's about to
start though now see I I feel like I'm
gonna fall off a lot so I'm just gonna
drink whenever I'm getting oh I'm gonna
go we can't all the same strategy wow
that hurts
this game suddenly got way hard 150 cc's
is really fast I'm doing like way good
right now way good Oh see this is a hard
time to drink because do we do it when
you're in the last place or do you do
when you're in first I thought there'd
be more rules to this game like when you
drink but I guess it's really up to you
as a player I think it's meant to keep
the game kind of pure how much did you
drink Cody I finish the beer oh my god
oh you just passed me now it's just
Mario Kart man now it's just Mario Kart
yeah
I just won Howie you cheated how did you
cheat just won the race without drinking
the beer I mean I was finished having
beer reviews of the game I mean it's a
classic game with Twitter I mean any
excuse to play Mario Kart oh yeah
definitely play again this is pretty
great Mario Kart gets you drunk quick I
think we should figure out a way to do
battle yeah all about battle mode yeah
battle mode is the best maybe each of
your balloons is like a shot and you
have like three shots Ronnie oh let's
set that up right now you know you want
to